Jill's been a flight attendant for years, does long flights to Europe and South America, where they're on the plane for 10 hours or more. And it's such close quarters, and customers can be so stressed out and get testy, and she and her co-workers, of course, always have to seem calm and courteous. They need to totally control the cabin.
吉尔当空乘已经很多年了，经常飞往欧洲和南美洲的长途航班，在飞机上一待就是10个小时甚至更久。机舱里空间狭小，乘客们往往压力很大，脾气也容易变得暴躁，而她和同事们自然必须时刻保持冷静和礼貌。他们需要完全掌控客舱。
And at the same time give off this illusion of being servants.
同时还要营造出一种服务者的假象。
Right.
没错。
When in reality, we're in control.
但实际上，我们才是掌控全局的人。
It's stressful, she says. And it's easy for them to get on each other's nerves, like with this flight attendant who was Jill's nemesis for a while.
她说，这压力很大。而且他们很容易看彼此不顺眼，比如吉尔曾经有个死对头，也是一名空乘。
She just talked a lot. I think that's what bothered me a lot. So during our downtime, going into the galley, sort of getting away from people, it would just be incessant talking. And it drove me nuts. And I think my silence would drive her nuts. So we didn't get along.
她就是话特别多。我想这就是最让我心烦的地方。所以当我们休息、走进备餐间想避开人群时，她还是会不停地说话。这简直让我抓狂。我想我的沉默也会让她抓狂。所以我们合不来。
Now, of course, when flight attendants snipe at each other, if they're in the middle of the aisle with the beverage cart--
当然，当空乘们互相讥讽时，如果正好处在过道中间推着餐车——
We have to do it in a way that the passengers don't know what's happening. For example, she would say, "can you get me some more Cokes from the galley?" And I would say, "we're out of Cokes."
我们必须做得让乘客察觉不到。例如，她会说：“你能从备餐间再给我拿些可乐吗？”我会回答：“可乐卖完了。”
And to the passengers next to us, that sounds completely normal. But she knows, and I know, that we're not out of Cokes. And she's stuck behind the beverage cart. She physically cannot get there and get them for herself. And so it is--
对于旁边的乘客来说，这听起来完全正常。但她知道，我也知道，可乐根本没卖完。而她被困在餐车后面，根本没法亲自去拿。所以这是——
It's war.
这就是战争。
It's war. It's this tiny, little symbol of hostility wrapped in this little sentence about Coca-Cola. She might try, like, "are you sure we're out of Cokes? Because I saw some back there." And I would say, "no, we're out." She'd be powerless.
这就是战争。这只是关于可口可乐的一句小话，却包裹着敌意的符号。她可能会试探说：“你确定可乐卖完了吗？因为我刚才看见后面还有。”我会说：“不，卖完了。”她就只能束手无策。
If we have to do another beverage service, she might take all the red wine. And so I have to ask her every time for a bottle of red wine. And I have to ask her for something every time I need it. It's these little, tiny things that you would never know.
如果我们还要进行下一次饮料服务，她可能会拿走所有的红酒。所以我每次想拿红酒都得向她开口。我每次需要什么都得求她。就是这些你永远不会知道的琐碎小事。
And then about 2, 2 and 1/2 hours into these overnight flights, Jill says, it'll be time for a sleep break. Some planes have special seats curtained off or hidden behind doors in special compartments, or up secret flights of stairs in certain planes, there are crew bunks above the overhead bins. Who knew?
在这些夜航航班飞行大约2到2个半小时后，吉尔说，就到了轮流休息的时间。有些飞机会有专门用帘子隔开的座位，或者隐藏在特殊舱门后的空间，有些飞机的行李架上方甚至有秘密楼梯，通向机组人员的卧铺。谁能想到呢？
It's a very tiny, little space, literally above the overhead bins.
那是一个非常狭小的空间，真的就在行李架上方。
So Jill would sometimes have to go to sleep with her enemy, with the nemesis. And she says that to function on the rest of the flight, they really do need to sleep, no kidding. And so they both know its truce.
所以吉尔有时不得不和她的敌人，和她的死对头一起睡觉。她说，为了在接下来的航程中保持工作状态，他们确实需要休息，不开玩笑。所以他们都知道，这是休战。
There is no disturbing the other person's sleep at all. I learned to not toss and turn, not clear my throat, just be very still. I imagine myself like a vampire in a coffin, so that I'm not disturbing the other person, even if I hate them.
绝对不能打扰对方睡觉。我学会了不翻来覆去，不清嗓子，就静静地待着。我把自己想象成棺材里的吸血鬼，这样我就不会打扰到对方，哪怕我恨她。
And then they lie there, side by side, at peace, hurdling through the air at over 500 miles an hour, each of them dreaming, presumably, very different dreams. Jill does not know what the nemesis would dream about, but she has certain dreams only when she's in the air.
然后他们就躺在那里，并排安睡，以每小时超过500英里的速度穿过天空，每个人都在做着大概完全不同的梦。吉尔不知道那个死对头会梦见什么，但她自己只有在空中时才会做特定的梦。
It's strange. I don't know if I should say this, but I do have crashing dreams on the plane. It's strange. I don't have those on the ground. I wonder if it's the turbulence.
很奇怪。我不知道该不该说，但在飞机上我确实会做坠机的梦。这很奇怪。我在地面上从不做这种梦。我怀疑是不是因为气流颠簸。
What happens in the crashing dreams?
坠机的梦里发生了什么？
We just crash.
我们就是坠机了。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Well, today on our program, "Same Bed, Different Dreams," we have stories of enemies sleeping together or working together or just stuck together in some way with very different hopes and goals, stories of deception and star-crossed haters. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天的节目《同床异梦》，我们有关于敌人在睡觉、工作或以某种方式被困在一起，却怀揣着截然不同的希望和目标的故事，有关于欺骗和受阻的怨敌的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Dream Weevil." That title's going to make more sense as this story goes on. Just trust me on that. In 1986, a man and woman ran into a US embassy in Vienna and said they needed asylum.
第一幕，“织梦者”。随着故事的展开，这个标题会变得更有意义。相信我就好了。1986年，一男一女跑进维也纳的美国大使馆，请求政治庇护。
They were from South Korea. And they told embassy officials this incredible story of kidnapping and intrigue, and being torn apart and thrown back together, and years of dreaming about escape from their kidnapper, while, at the same time, convincing their kidnapper that what they really wanted to do was stay with him. Nancy Updike has the story.
他们来自韩国。他们向大使馆官员讲述了一个关于绑架和阴谋、被强行拆散又被撮合在一起的惊人故事，讲述了他们多年来梦寐以求地想逃离绑架者，同时又要让绑架者相信，他们真正想做的是留在他身边。南希·厄普代克带来了这个故事。
The woman who was kidnapped was a famous South Korean actress named Choi Eun-Hee. I read a book about it by a writer and film producer named Paul Fischer. He spent years researching this story.
被绑架的女性是韩国著名女演员崔银姬。我读过保罗·费舍尔写的关于这件事的书，他是一位作家兼电影制片人。他花了好几年时间研究这个故事。
She was compared at the time to Elizabeth Taylor.
当时她被比作伊丽莎白·泰勒。
Elizabeth Taylor. Imagine if Elizabeth Taylor, past her prime but still famous from all her iconic roles, had just disappeared one day. Choi was that beautiful, that much of an icon in South Korea, and she was gone. She found out pretty quickly who had arranged this.
伊丽莎白·泰勒。想象一下，如果伊丽莎白·泰勒，虽然过了巅峰期但仍因标志性角色而家喻户晓，有一天突然消失了。崔在韩国就是那么美，影响力那么大，但她失踪了。她很快就发现是谁策划了这一切。
When Choi was kidnapped in 1978, she was put on a boat, and the boat went to Namp'o Harbor in North Korea. And she actually has a photo, which is in the book, of her very first meeting with Kim Jong-il. He was there waiting for her off the boat with a photographer. And he had his photographer take a photo and then send it to her as a sort of--
1978年崔被绑架时，她被送上一艘船，船开往朝鲜南浦港。书里有她第一次见到金正日的照片，那是她下船时，对方带着摄影师在那里等着她。他让摄影师拍了张照，然后送给她，算是某种——
You'll want to remember this.
你会想记住这一刻的。
Exactly, remember that time.
没错，记住那个时刻。
Remember that time I had you kidnapped and brought to me?
记住我把你绑架到我面前的那一刻？
And it's a terrible picture. And he's beaming and smiley, and she's got her face covered.
那是一张糟糕的照片。他满面春风，而她遮住了脸。
For years, her family and her country didn't know where she was. This happened in 1978. Choi was in her 50s. And her first sickening guess as to why she had been taken was that Kim Jong-il had brought her to North Korea to be a mistress for his father, the Great Leader, Kim Il-sung, who was ruling the country at the time.
多年来，她的家人和国家都不知道她在哪里。这件事发生在1978年。崔当时50多岁。她对绑架动机的第一个令人作呕的猜测是，金正日把她带到朝鲜是想让她做他父亲、时任最高领导人金日成的玩物。
But no, it seemed that Kim Jong-il himself was just a very big fan of Choi's movies. He put her up in a fancy villa, surrounded by walls and barbed wire and armed guards. She called it in her memoir "Las Vegas meets Vladivostok." Kim Jong-il brought her out to display at parties. That was Choi's life for five years, until one particular night and one special party.
但并不是，看起来金正日本人只是崔电影的超级粉丝。他把她安顿在一栋围着高墙、铁丝网和武装警卫的豪华别墅里。她在回忆录中将其称为“拉斯维加斯遇见符拉迪沃斯托克”。金正日带她出席各种派对。这就是崔五年来的生活，直到某天晚上的一个特殊派对。
Choi had been there for a while. And she was standing somewhere in the center of the room.
崔在那里待了一段时间。她当时正站在房间中央。
And she was used to these parties by this point.
那时候她已经习惯了这种派对。
Exactly. They were routine. She had started feeling repulsed by them. People got drunk and groped women, and then they went on forever. And somebody had already told her that this is going to be such a great evening for you. And she nodded along, because she was used to hyperbole about everything.
没错。这些都是家常便饭。她开始对这些聚会感到厌恶。人们喝得烂醉，猥亵女性，而且派对没完没了。已经有人告诉过她：“今晚对你来说会是一个很棒的夜晚。”她只是随口应付，因为她已经习惯了对一切事物的夸大其词。
Choi had no idea that Kim Jong-il that night was planning to show off for the first time another person he had acquired, the man who had directed or produced almost all of Choi's movies, her ex-husband, Shin Sang-Ok. Shin and Choi each didn't know that the other was also in the country. Shin had been brought there the same way Choi was. But he tried to escape twice, so he was thrown in a prison camp for a couple of years.
崔不知道金正日那天晚上计划第一次炫耀他获得的另一个人，也就是几乎执导或制作了崔所有电影的前夫——申相玉。申和崔都不知道对方也在朝鲜。申是以和崔同样的方式被带到这里的。但他试图逃跑两次，所以被扔进监狱关了几年。
The best way to describe Shin-- Steven Spielberg's a good comparison, in a sense, as well. He made films that were very good, very commercial, very popular. And he also produced other people's films, had his own studio. And he was the most powerful popular filmmaker in South Korea, arguably in all of Southeast Asia for most of the '60s and into the '70s.
描述申最好的方式是拿史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格做类比。他制作的电影非常好，非常商业化，也非常受欢迎。他还制作别人的电影，有自己的工作室。在60年代和70年代的大部分时间里，他是韩国、甚至可以说是整个东南亚最有权势的流行电影制作人。
And Shin, 10 days prior to this, he was still in a prison camp, got released, and for 10 days in a villa, they fattened him up, tried to restore him to health. He arrives at the party when it's already in full flow. And he walks inside, and as soon as he enters there's applause.
就在此前的10天，申还在监狱里，随后被释放。在别墅里被关了10天，他们把他喂胖，试图恢复他的健康。当派对进行到最高潮时，他走了进来。他一走进去，现场就响起了掌声。
What an insane thing. 10 days ago, you're in a prison camp. You walk in, and you're the life of the party. Everyone's applauding.
太荒唐了。10天前你还在监狱里。你一走进去，就成了派对的核心人物。每个人都在鼓掌。
Exactly. And in the pictures, his face still looks emaciated. You can tell he's just gone through something terrible. The suit doesn't fit.
没错。照片里他的脸看起来仍然消瘦。你能看出来他刚经历过什么可怕的事情。西装也不合身。
Now Choi doesn't see Shin come in. She just hears people start applauding.
崔并没有看见申走进来。她只是听见人们开始鼓掌。
And Choi is sort of even unfazed by this. Any time Kim does anything, people get up and applaud.
崔对此甚至无动于衷。金正日做任何事，人们都会起立鼓掌。
She didn't know why people were applauding. She had no idea.
她不知道人们为什么鼓掌。她完全不知情。
Exactly, until somebody says, "why don't you look happy? Look who's here." And she turns around. And it's been five years. Shin's got the marks of having been tortured in a prison camp. She doesn't recognize him right away.
没错，直到有人说：“你怎么看起来不高兴？看看谁来了。”她转过身。已经五年了。申身上带着在监狱受刑的痕迹。她没有立刻认出他来。
And from that point on, Kim Jong-il was pulling them together. And they, sort of shell shocked, hugged one another. And then were then moved around, like blocking in a movie scene, by Kim Jong-il.
从那一刻起，金正日就把他们凑在了一起。他们像是受到惊吓一样拥抱了彼此。随后又像是在拍电影场景调度一样，被金正日摆布着。
What, like stand here, sit here.
什么意思，像是站在这里、坐在那里？
Stand here. You stand next to me. Smile to the cameras. They were sort of the guests of honor.
站在这里。你站在我旁边。对摄像机微笑。他们就像是贵宾。
Famous people don't get to pick their fans. Kim Jong-il was a super fan who was also, unfortunately, the son of the all powerful leader of a totalitarian state. Shin and Choi had made their best movies together. Kim loved their movies, and he wanted them to be a couple, just like they were in their heyday. So he arranged it, parent trap style. He told them at the party that, guess what, he had a newly remodeled villa for them that they would be living in from now on, together.
名人没法选择自己的粉丝。金正日是一个超级粉丝，同时不幸的是，他还是一个极权国家至高无上领导人的儿子。申和崔曾一起制作了他们最好的电影。金正日热爱他们的电影，他希望他们能像全盛时期那样重新成为一对。所以他像《天生一对》里那样安排了这一切。他在派对上告诉他们，猜怎么着，他给他们准备了一栋新装修的别墅，从今往后他们要住在一起。
Making a joke, I think he said something like, the newlyweds are going to want to be alone now.
我想他开玩笑说了句类似“新婚夫妇现在肯定想独处了”的话。
What a weirdo.
真是个怪人。
And had them taken to a car, and by all accounts, seemed extremely pleased, and expected them to be equally so. And it's the moment right after that when they went back to the villa, closed the bathroom door, turned the faucets on--
他让人把他们带回了车里。据各方说法，他看起来非常满意，并期待他们也能同样满意。就在那之后他们回到别墅，关上浴室门，打开水龙头的那一刻——
In order to talk privately, they turned the faucets on so they can whisper and actually have a private conversation.
为了私下交谈，他们打开水龙头，这样他们就可以耳语，进行真正的私下对话。
Exactly. And they just asked one another what had happened. The way she describes it is sort of a lovely moment, where she asks him, what happened to you? And he said, a lot. I'll tell you some other time. And then he asks her, what happened to you? And she says, a lot. I'll tell you some other time.
没错。他们只是询问对方发生了什么。她描述的那种方式是一种可爱的时刻，她问他：你经历了什么？他说：很多。以后再告诉你。然后他问她：你经历了什么？她说：很多。以后再告诉你。
And Shin kind of gingerly, again, asked her, you know, you looked very smiley and happy. And have you been brainwashed? And then she made a joke about how the director can't even recognize acting anymore. And both of them were finally able to be genuine with someone. And they spent the next several hours going through everything.
申小心翼翼地又问她：你看起来笑得很开心。你被洗脑了吗？然后她开了个玩笑，说导演连演戏都认不出来了。他们两人终于能够对某人展现真实自我。接下来的几个小时里，他们讲述了发生的一切。
Shin and Choi made a long-term plan and a short-term plan. Long-term, they were going to escape. But they would wait until they could do it right so they wouldn't be caught. Their short-term plan involved a small tape recorder, which they were able to get, because one of the weird privileges of their captivity was that they were allowed to shop at a department store that sold things that were out of reach for most people in the country, like tape recorders.
申和崔制定了长期计划和短期计划。长期计划是逃跑。但他们会等待机会，直到能够完美执行而不被抓住。他们的短期计划涉及到一个小录音机，他们之所以能弄到这个，是因为他们被俘的怪异特权之一，就是允许在一家百货公司购物，那里出售大多数国家普通人无法触及的商品，比如录音机。
Kim Jong-il had long- and short-term plans of his own for them. He told them that soon he would summon them to talk about his vision for their future. Then seven months went by.
金正日对他们也有长期和短期计划。他告诉他们，很快就会召见他们，谈谈他对他们未来的构想。然后七个月过去了。
And during those months, Shin and Choi spent hours nearly every week in Kim's huge film archive. He wanted Shin and Choi to see it and be impressed, and they were. Kim didn't just loved their movies. He loved all movies.
在那几个月里，申和崔每周几乎都要花几个小时在金正日巨大的电影资料库里。他想让申和崔看到并留下深刻印象，他们确实被震撼了。金正日不仅热爱他们的电影。他热爱所有电影。
It was against the law for ordinary North Koreans to watch foreign films. But Kim had set up a massive bootlegging operation running in countries all over the world so he could build up his private collection with every movie ever made, or as close as he could get. The archive was three stories high and heavily guarded, at least two screening rooms, all for Kim only, and now for Shin and Choi. Shin was bowled over by every detail.
对于普通朝鲜人来说，观看外国电影是违法的。但金正日建立了一个巨大的走私网络，在世界各国运作，以便他能建立起拥有每一部有史以来拍摄的电影的私人收藏，或者尽可能接近这个目标。这个资料库有三层楼高，守卫森严，至少有两个放映室，全部仅供金正日一人使用，现在又加上了申和崔。申被每一个细节震撼了。
The way the building itself was set up to run, and with admiration over how Kim had set up his own archive, and how well everything was kept, geeking out over the air conditioning settings and how he was preserving the celluloid, and how everything was cataloged, and the staff, and then how large it was.
包括建筑本身的运作方式，以及对金正日建立自己资料库的方式的钦佩，对一切保持得如此完好的赞叹，对空调设置的钻研，他如何保存胶片，如何进行编目，员工配备，以及规模之大。
How is it categorized? Was it by year or by genre or by director?
是怎么分类的？是按年份、流派还是导演？
It went by country first. And then I think it went by year as they got them in. And then there's a lovely touch where the South Korean films are in a normal air conditioning room, and then the North Korean films were in the most lavish storage and screening room in the whole building.
首先是按国家分类。然后我想随着他们拿到电影，就是按年份分类。还有一个可爱的细节，南韩电影放在普通空调房间里，而北韩电影却存放在整栋建筑中最奢华的存储和放映室里。
The films were dubbed into Korean after being painstakingly transcribed, sometimes by Americans. There was an American defector-- he was one of several, actually-- who had been there since 1965. And one of his jobs was transcribing American films, but just by listening, because he wasn't allowed to watch them.
这些电影经过辛苦的转录后被配成韩语，有时由美国人完成。有一位美国投诚者——实际上他是其中的一位——从1965年就在那里了。他的工作之一就是转录美国电影，但他只能通过听力，因为他不允许观看。
Yeah. And he wouldn't know that they were films, because they gave him and the other American defectors the audio. For some reason they chopped up the film soundtracks into different bits in the wrong order so they wouldn't--
是啊。他甚至不知道那是电影，因为他们只给了他和其他美国投诚者音频。出于某种原因，他们把电影原声带剪辑成了错误的顺序，这样他们就不会——
Know what they were doing?
知道自己在做什么？
Exactly, or enjoy them. But he had this experience of transcribing, and then suddenly realizing, wait, this is Mary Poppins.
没错，或者享受它们。但他有那种转录的经历，突然意识到：等等，这是《欢乐满人间》。
Shin and Choi spent dozens and dozens of hours watching one movie after another in the screening rooms at the film archive and in their villa, which was also outfitted to show movies. They did that for months, until finally they got word. Kim is ready to meet with you. They went, and they brought the tape recorder.
申和崔在资料库的放映室以及也装有电影放映设备的别墅里，花了无数个小时一部接一部地看电影。他们这样做了几个月，直到终于接到消息：金正日准备见你们了。他们去了，并带上了录音机。
And the second they walked in, Choi had the tape recorder in her purse, and she flicked it on. And I think unexpectedly, Kim Jong-il just talked at them, mostly, for two hours.
他们一进去，崔就把录音机藏在手提包里并打开了。我想意想不到的是，金正日大部分时间只是对着他们说了两个小时的话。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
Kim Jong-il spoke very, very fast. And his mind went all over the place. And he had a very intimidating waiter slash bodyguard who kept walking into to refill drinks and empty ashtrays.
金正日说话非常非常快。他的思维跳跃极大。还有一个非常令人生畏的侍者兼保镖，不停地走进来加酒、清理烟灰缸。
Shin and Choi wanted to record Kim for two reasons. First, they knew they might not be able to escape. Maybe they would be killed, and their children and friends would just never know what had happened to them. A recording, if they could smuggle it out, would at least be proof of where they'd been.
申和崔想录下金正日的话有两个原因。首先，他们知道自己可能无法逃脱。也许他们会被杀，他们的孩子和朋友永远不会知道发生了什么。如果有录音，只要他们能把它偷运出去，至少能证明他们曾经在哪里。
The second reason to record him was that they knew that Kim would insist, they say, publicly, that they had come to North Korea on their own, voluntarily. Shin and Choi were hoping that, in their private conversation, Kim might admit to having had them kidnapped and brought to him. And he almost, almost did, by making a joke.
录下他话的第二个原因是，他们知道金正日会坚持要求他们公开宣称自己是自愿来到朝鲜的。申和崔希望在他们的私下交谈中，金正日可能会开玩笑地承认是他绑架并把他们带到这里的。他差一点，差一点就说了，通过开玩笑的方式。
In the first couple of minutes of their conversation, Kim talked about how he had brought Choi over first in order to entice Shin to North Korea. I say joke because Kim laughs as he says it. And then all three of them laugh.
在谈话的最初几分钟里，金正日谈到了他是如何先诱骗崔，以此引诱申来到朝鲜的。我说这是开玩笑，因为金正日说这话时笑了。然后他们三个人都笑了。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
It's tyrant management 101. If he laughs, you laugh. The rest of what Kim said in that conversation-- well, he said a lot of things. But the main thing was, North Korean movies are bad, and I'm sick of it.
这是暴君管理101。如果他笑了，你就得笑。金正日在那次谈话中说的其余内容——好吧，他说了不少事情。但主要观点是：朝鲜电影很烂，我受够了。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
They were making the same film over and over again, and that there were too long and too boring, and history lessons and too melodramatic. And he says there's too much crying. I didn't tell anybody to put in so much crying.
他们一直在拍同一部电影，电影太长太无聊，充满了说教和过度煽情。他说有太多的哭戏。我没叫谁放这么多哭戏。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
Kim Jong-il told Shin and Choi that he knew he was the only person in the country who could get away with saying what he was saying. And he told them not to repeat any of it. He said, when it comes to movies, we are in kindergarten. And other countries, like South Korea, are in college.
金正日告诉申和崔，他知道自己是这个国家唯一一个可以畅所欲言的人。他告诉他们不要重复他的话。他说：在电影方面，我们还在上幼儿园。而其他国家，比如韩国，已经在上大学了。
He said, if we don't catch up in the next 10 years, our movies are going to be the worst of the worst movies in the world. The problem, he said, just between us, is that people in North Korea had it too easy. They had things handed to them. They didn't have to hustle, like Shin and Choi did.
他说：如果我们未来10年赶不上，我们的电影将成为世界上最烂的电影。他私下对他们说，问题在于朝鲜人民过得太安逸了。他们习惯了坐享其成。他们不像申和崔那样必须努力拼搏。
There's a point in the tape where he tells them that-- and I think I'm going to paraphrase a bit. But he says, there's no incentive in socialism to do any better.
录音里有一个点，他告诉他们——我想我会稍微意译一下。但他说道：在社会主义制度下，没有动力去做到更好。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
He says, my screenwriters, they'll write something, they'll get their rations. The other guys make a film, they'll get their rations.
他说：我的编剧，他们写点东西就能拿到配给。其他人拍电影，也能拿到配给。
So they get paid no matter what, as long as they just turn out the work.
所以无论如何他们都会拿到报酬，只要交差就行。
Exactly, and follow orders. And he seemed very conscious that he needs someone who pushes himself more than that, who's used to having to do more than that to earn his keep.
没错，听命行事就好。他似乎非常清醒地意识到，他需要一个不仅限于此的人，一个习惯于付出更多努力来换取报酬的人。
Kim Jong-il never mentioned another possible reason why North Korea's movies were wooden and unambitious, like fear. He, Kim Jong-il, had written the book, the only book in North Korea about the right way to make movies and think about movies. It's called On the Art of the Cinema . It's still in print.
金正日从未提及朝鲜电影呆板且缺乏野心的另一个可能原因，比如恐惧。他，金正日，写过关于拍摄电影和思考电影的正确方式的书，也就是朝鲜唯一的一本电影书。书名是《电影艺术论》。现在还在印刷。
Everyone involved in North Korea's film industry in the 1980s had to have been aware of the potential consequences of doing something as unpatriotic or insulting as trying to realize their own independent artistic vision. Without Kim's explicit blessing, and his father's, it was better to be crappy than sorry.
80年代参与朝鲜电影业的每个人，一定都意识到了实现自己独立艺术愿景这种不爱国或侮辱行为的潜在后果。没有金正日及其父亲的明确恩准，烂一点总比后悔好。
The conversation continued. Shin and Choi murmured that North Korea citizens were fortunate to have a comrade leader who understood films so well. Kim Jong-il agreed. With his permission, the three of them got into critiquing specific films, a North Korean one called The Star of Korea , and while they were at it, a Soviet film called Mother that had a dying scene they all agreed had been atrocious.
谈话继续。申和崔低声说朝鲜公民有幸拥有一位如此懂电影的同志领袖。金正日表示赞同。在他的允许下，三人开始批评特定电影，比如一部叫《朝鲜之星》的北韩电影，还有在谈话中顺带提到了苏联电影《母亲》，他们一致认为里面的死亡场景烂透了。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[韩语对话]
They were three movie lovers talking about what they loved. And Kim Jong-il's big plan for Shin and Choi was that he wanted them to make North Korean movies good, so that they could compete with films coming out of the West and win awards and be shown in theaters all over the world. He wanted Choi to act in the movies and Shin to direct them. Shin could have his own film company, just like he used to have. Shin wanted to call the company Shin Film, a very bold request in the circumstances.
他们是三个电影爱好者在谈论他们所热爱的东西。金正日对申和崔的宏大计划是，他想让他们拍出优秀的朝鲜电影，这样就能与西方电影竞争，赢得奖项，并在世界各地的影院放映。他想要崔在电影中表演，申负责执导。申可以拥有自己的电影公司，就像他过去那样。申想把公司命名为“申影业”，在这种情况下这是一个非常大胆的要求。
Yeah, nothing in North Korea had been called anything other than The Worker's Paradise this or The Party this or the Supreme Leader this, or Kim Il-sung University. So it was a big deal. But it's also very telling of Shin that, even in this surreal situation, his first instinct is, OK, OK, OK, but can we give the company my name?
是啊，朝鲜没有任何东西不叫“天堂劳动者”什么的，或者“党”什么的，或者“最高领导人”什么的，或者是“金日成大学”。所以这绝对是一件大事。但这也是申的特质，即使在这种超现实的情况下，他的第一直觉依然是：好吧，好吧，但我能用我的名字命名公司吗？
In film noir, someone is always using someone, and often people are using each other. And we don't find out until the end who gets away with what. Shin and Choi knew that their only chance of escape would be to convince Kim Jong-il to let them film and work in the West. Kim Jong-il knew that if he wanted good movies, he had to give Shin and Choi enough freedom to create them. So all three of them wanted to make great movies. But--
在黑色电影中，总有人在利用别人，而且往往是互相利用。我们直到最后才知道谁逃脱了什么。申和崔知道他们逃跑的唯一机会是说服金正日让他们在西方拍摄和工作。金正日知道如果他想要好电影，就必须给申和崔足够的创作自由。所以他们三个人都想拍出伟大的电影。但是——
Same bed, different dreams. Kim Jong-il wanted the films for his own purposes. And they needed the films to get away from him. And it's almost like his ambition of making films that the world will respect completely overtook any sense of logic.
同床异梦。金正日为了自己的目的需要这些电影。而他们需要这些电影来逃离他。这简直就像他制作电影的野心，要拍出世界尊重的电影，完全压倒了任何逻辑。
So the first film Shin and Choi shot had sequences that they shot in Eastern Europe, standing in for the Hague. And they showed Kim Jong-il the film. He said, this is fantastic. It's like a European film. It's the best thing we've ever made, allowed them to start showing it. And it never crossed his mind that they had done exactly what he'd forbidden his own filmmakers to do forever for a reason.
所以申和崔拍摄的第一部电影，有一些序列是在东欧拍摄的，假装是在海牙。他们向金正日展示了这部电影。他说：这太棒了。这就像欧洲电影。这是我们拍过最好的东西，并允许他们开始放映。他从未想过他们做了他一直禁止自己电影人做的事，而且是有原因的。
They'd been forbidden to show the world outside North Korea.
他们被禁止向外界展示北韩。
They showed people things that they hadn't been able to see almost in a lifetime for some people in North Korea by 1983, 1984. And the second that film started playing in cinemas in North Korea, the North Korean audiences didn't take in necessarily the higher production values.
他们向人们展示了在1983年、1984年以前，一些朝鲜人一辈子都看不到的东西。当那部电影开始在朝鲜影院上映时，朝鲜观众未必是吸收了更高的制作价值。
All they could talk about was the first 10, 15 minutes shot on the streets of Prague where, OK, wait, the buildings look amazing. People are walking into businesses. They're all dressed differently. There's cars. What?
他们谈论的都是在布拉格街头拍摄的前10、15分钟，因为：等等，建筑看起来太惊人了。人们走进商店。他们的着装都不一样。还有汽车。什么情况？
That's what really had an impact, because up until then they had been told, you are the luckiest people in the world. The Worker's Paradise is the only place in the world where people have peace and freedom. And suddenly they saw that that wasn't true.
这就是真正产生影响的原因，因为在此之前他们一直被告知：你们是世界上最幸运的人。“工人天堂”是世界上唯一让人们拥有和平和自由的地方。突然间他们看到那并不是真的。
How do you know that that's what people thought?
你是怎么知道那是人们的想法的？
I was lucky enough to meet and speak to people who'd escaped from North Korea who were at varying ages at the time that they were able to watch these films. And there's another German researcher in Japan now called Johannes Schonherr who's done quite a lot of talking to defectors about the same thing. And one of the things that's fascinating is that Shin and Choi's films had a huge impact straightaway. There would have been people in their late 30s who'd never seen anything of the outside world that hadn't been filtered.
我有幸见到了那些从朝鲜逃出来的人，他们当时正处于不同年龄段，能够观看这些电影。现在在日本还有另一位德国研究员叫约翰内斯·肖恩赫尔，他做了很多与逃北者关于同一件事的访谈。令人着迷的一点是，申和崔的电影立即产生了巨大影响。当时会有一些30多岁的人，从未见过任何未经筛选的外部世界影像。
But it wasn't just that people suddenly were able to see footage of the outside world. But Shin and Choi made a film called Love, Love, My Love, which was literally the first love story in North Korean culture post 1945 that wasn't about love of the leader or love the party. It was literally the first time people were able to go to the cinema, and see something that was about two people falling in love. And it was the first time teenagers had pictures on their wall of a matinee idol, of anybody other than the leaders.
但不仅仅是人们突然能够看到外部世界的影像。申和崔制作了一部名为《爱情，爱情，我的爱情》的电影，这字面上是1945年后朝鲜文化中第一部不关乎爱领袖或爱党的爱情故事。这绝对是人们第一次能够走进影院，看到关于两个人坠入爱河的故事。这也是青少年第一次在墙上贴偶像海报，而不是领导人的照片。
Shin directed seven films for Kim Jong-il. And then in March 1986, he and Choi went to a hotel in Vienna for some film business, managed to grab a separate taxi from their North Korean minders, sped to the US Embassy, and ran in. They were debriefed by the CIA, and later by South Korean intelligence. And they were interviewed by The Washington Post and other media outlets.
申为金正日执导了七部电影。然后在1986年3月，他和崔为了电影业务去了维也纳的一家酒店，设法避开了他们的北韩监护人，坐上另一辆出租车，疾驰到美国大使馆，跑了进去。他们接受了中央情报局的简报，后来又接受了韩国情报部门的采访。他们还接受了《华盛顿邮报》和其他媒体的采访。
And stories about North Korea are always hard to fact check. For parts of Shin and Choi's story, their recollections, their interpretations are all there is. But the movies exist. The recording of Kim exists.
关于朝鲜的故事总是很难核实。对于申和崔故事的一部分，他们的回忆、他们的解读就是全部了。但电影存在，金正日的录音也存在。
Kim Jong-il had told Shin and Choi in the recording that when people ask them why they were in North Korea, they should say freedom, for true artistic freedom. For Shin, there was some bitter truth to that, because South Korea, at the time Shin and Choi were kidnapped, had been a military dictatorship with very heavy-handed censors.
金正日在那段录音中告诉申和崔，当人们问他们为什么要来朝鲜时，他们应该说是为了自由，为了真正的艺术自由。对于申来说，这其中有一些苦涩的真相，因为在申和崔被绑架时，南韩是一个实行严厉审查制度的军事独裁国家。
Shin's studio had been shut down by the South Korean government in 1975. His career was in ruins. In North Korea, Shin got to make films again. He wrote unabashedly in his autobiography how much he had loved making movies there.
申的电影公司在1975年被南韩政府关闭。他的职业生涯毁了。在朝鲜，申又可以拍电影了。他在自传中毫无顾忌地写下了他有多么热爱在那里拍电影。
Shin always spoke of North Korea as the place he associated film freedom with and creative freedom with, because he could ask for anything and get it. In one episode, he asked for a model train to blow up for a scene, and he was given a real train packed with explosives on rails to blow up if he wanted to.
申总是把朝鲜形容为他将“电影自由”和“创作自由”联系在一起的地方，因为他可以提出任何要求并得到满足。在一次拍摄中，他要求一辆模型火车来爆炸以配合场景，结果他得到了一辆装满炸药的真火车，如果他想的话随时可以引爆。
And if he asked for a wind machine, he was sent helicopters. And if he wanted fake snow, everybody was flown to a mountain. There was no expense spared.
如果他要鼓风机，他们就送来直升机。如果他想要人造雪，所有人都被空运到山上。不惜任何成本。
Kim Jong-il felt like the larger than life film producer that you hear about. And he didn't have the downside that a film producer usually has, because a film producer usually has to say no every now and then. We don't have enough money. We don't have enough time.
金正日感觉就像你听到的那些超越生活现实的电影制片人。而且他没有电影制片人通常有的负面一面，因为电影制片人通常时不时得说“不”。我们钱不够。我们时间不够。
Shin and Choi had remarried in North Korea at Kim Jong-il's suggestion. And it ended up being a real marriage. They were together until Shin died in 2006. They seemed to have been each other's big love in life, besides movies. Although Shin loved movies more than Choi did, maybe a lot more.
申和崔在金正日的建议下在朝鲜再婚了。这最终成为了一场真正的婚姻。他们一直在一起直到申在2006年去世。除了电影，他们似乎是彼此一生中的至爱。尽管申比崔更热爱电影，也许爱得多得多。
In their shared memoir of their time in North Korea, it goes from his voice to her voice, back and forth. And kind of the second they start making films, her voice kind of disappears entirely. And it's all his from then on. And it's about escaping, but in equal measure it's about making the films, almost as if he's writing a memoir of his time in Hollywood or something.
在他们共同在朝鲜度过时光的回忆录中，叙述在两人声音之间来回切换。到了他们开始拍电影的时候，她的声音基本完全消失了。从那以后全是他的声音。书中关于逃跑，但同样也关于拍电影，几乎就像他在写自己在好莱坞度过的时光。
Choi's 88 years old, living in South Korea. When Paul was researching his book, he interviewed her for it. And he asked her about Shin and the movies they made in North Korea.
崔88岁了，住在南韩。当保罗研究他的书时，他采访了她。他问起申以及他们在朝鲜拍摄的电影。
And when I met her and spoke to her, you could sense the impatience that if she had been able to get out of there three years earlier and not made any of the films, she would have been very happy to do so.
当我见到她并与她交谈时，你可以感觉到那种焦躁，如果她能早三年离开那里，没有拍任何电影，她会非常高兴。
And him not so much.
而他可能没那么高兴。
Even great love can't protect you from the other person wanting what they want.
即使是伟大的爱情也无法保护你免受对方想要的东西所干扰。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Paul Fischer's book about all this is called A Kim Jong-il Production. Coming up, people sharing beds-- actual beds-- with very different dreams. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。保罗·费舍尔关于这一切的书名为《金正日作品》。稍后，分享床铺——真正的床铺——却怀揣完全不同梦想的人。那是芝加哥公共广播电台的《美国生活》，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Same Bed, Different Dreams." We have stories of people who are bound closely together. They are stuck with each other, but with very different hopes and goals. We have arrived at Act Two, of our program, Act Two, "Smell You Later."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《同床异梦》。我们有那些紧密结合在一起的人们的故事。他们被困在一起，却有着截然不同的希望和目标。现在到了节目的第二幕，《稍后闻你》。
There are all kinds of work situations where people very literally share an actual bed so they can do their jobs. These are people who share a bed that they are not ever in at the same time. This happens in lots of places. It has different names-- shift beds, hot sheeting, hot bedding.
在很多工作环境中，人们确实共享一张床，这样他们就能完成工作。这些人共享一张床，但他们从不在同一时间使用。这发生在很多地方。它有不同的名字——轮班床、热铺、热床。
Flight attendants do this. The flight attendant, Jill, who you heard at the top of the program, used to sleep in an apartment in New York with bunk beds that she shared with a bunch of airline people. Guys who work on oil rigs and oil fields do it too.
空乘人员这样做。你在节目开头听到的空乘吉尔，曾经在纽约的一间公寓里睡双层床，和一群航空业的人共享。在石油钻井平台和油田工作的人也这样做。
Basically the only rules that we had was basically we had to swap out sheets every time that we're going to go to our shift. Swap out your sheets and put my sheets.
基本上我们唯一的规则就是每次我们要去换班时，都必须换床单。换上你的床单，铺上我的床单。
This guy works in Carlsbad, New Mexico. When he and a friend first moved there two years ago to do fracking, to save money, they rented this small RV, just like 15 feet long, one bed in it.
这个人在新墨西哥州卡尔斯巴德工作。两年前他和朋友刚搬到那里做水力压裂时，为了省钱，他们租了一辆小房车，只有15英尺长，里面只有一张床。
He worked nights. His friend worked days. They had a rule to always shower before getting in the bed.
他上夜班。他朋友上白班。他们有一个规则：上床前必须洗澡。
The sheets, my friend's always been real picky on that. He always had the color blue. I always liked red sheets, something bright. So every time that I'd leave, he always had my red sheets on. Every time that I'd leave, I'd always put his blue sheets on.
床单方面，我朋友一直很挑剔。他总喜欢蓝色。我一直喜欢红床单，颜色鲜艳的那种。所以我每次离开，他总是换上我的红床单。每次我离开，我也总是换上他的蓝床单。
And plus, we never got the same sheets, because we never wanted to be mixed up and stuff. That'd be pretty messed up. I'd be smelling him, and he'd be smelling me and stuff.
而且我们从不混用床单，因为我们不想混在一起。那样会很糟糕。我会闻到他，他也会闻到我之类的。
Migrant workers also have these shift beds in some places in farms around the country. In New York, the main agricultural product is milk. There are 5,000 dairy farms in the state, and lots of them operate 24/7, so shift beds are common.
移民工人在全国一些农场也有这种轮班床。在纽约，主要的农产品是牛奶。州内有5000个奶牛场，很多都24/7运作，所以轮班床很常见。
Stephanie Foo went to see the shift beds at one of those farms.
斯蒂芬妮·傅去看了看那些农场的轮班床。
I didn't see any cows on the farm. And more surprising, I didn't smell them. Instead, there were just sweet smelling bales of hay in a field with three mobile homes on it. Mexican music was blasting out of the closest one.
我在农场里没看到任何奶牛。更令人惊讶的是，我没闻到味儿。相反，田野里只有干草堆，散发着甜味，上面放着三辆移动住房。最靠近的那辆正播放着震耳欲聋的墨西哥音乐。
My interpreter, Antonia, and I knock on the door. And as soon as we step inside, the stench of manure is overpowering from a few mud-caked boots in the corner.
我和翻译安东尼娅敲了敲门。我们一踏进去，角落里几双沾满泥巴的靴子散发出的粪便恶臭就令人窒息。
It's a two-bedroom trailer with holes in the floor and black mold growing in the cabinets, and clutter everywhere, roaches, and jars of Nescafe and sugar and cans of beans, Coronas. It's 7:00 PM, and we're there during the shift change.
这是一辆两居室的拖车，地板上有洞，橱柜里长着黑霉，到处都是杂乱的东西、蟑螂，还有雀巢咖啡罐、糖、罐装豆子、科罗娜啤酒。现在是晚上7点，我们正处于换班时间。
There are four or five guys milling around, all Mexican, all undocumented. Some are just getting home, and others, like this one guy, Jose, are just making up for work. Jose's shy, but he smiles a lot. He shows Antonia and me where he sleeps.
有四五个人在走动，都是墨西哥人，都没有证件。有些人刚下班回来，而其他人，比如那个叫何塞的家伙，正准备上班。何塞很害羞，但总是笑。他带着安东尼娅和我想看他睡哪儿。
Oh, wow. There's a bed in the bathroom.
哦，天哪。浴缸里有一张床。
Jose lifts up the bed's mattress and a wooden plank underneath, knocking over a jar of change, and--
何塞掀起床垫和下面的一块木板，撞翻了一罐硬币，然后——
Oh. Are you in the bathtub?
哦。你是在浴缸里吗？
Si. [SPEAKING SPANISH].
是的。[西班牙语]。
He joked that if he wanted to take a bath, he could just lift up his bed and get in. His bed is a wooden plank placed over the tub. There are a couple of pillows shoved over the faucet, so that the knobs don't turn and flood the tub while he's sleeping. It's happened before.
他开玩笑说，如果想洗澡，他只需要掀开床就能进去。他的床是架在浴缸上的一块木板。有几个枕头塞在水龙头上，这样旋钮就不会转动导致浴缸溢水。以前发生过这种情况。
Including the bathtub bed, there are a total of seven beds in the two-bedroom mobile home. Sometimes up to 13 people live here and share the seven beds, sleeping in shifts. Jose explained how it works. No, there are no alarm clocks. No need for them.
包括浴缸里的那张床，这间两居室的移动住房里一共有七张床。有时最多有13人住在这里，共享七张床，轮班睡觉。何塞解释了它是如何运作的。不，没有闹钟。不需要闹钟。
When you get off work, you find someone who has an opposite shift from you, and you wake them up so you can take their bad.
下班时，你会找到一个和你轮班相反的人，把他叫醒，好让你睡他的床。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
Jose says, OK, I get here at 4:00 AM, and my friend is sleeping. And I tap him on his blanket, and it goes like this.
何塞说，好吧，我凌晨4点到这里，我朋友在睡觉。我敲他的毯子，大概是这样。
[SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
Who is it?
是谁？
[SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
Me, Jose.
是我，何塞。
[SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
It's 5:00. It's 5:00. It's 5:00. And they try to go back to sleep. Let me sleep. And I say, it's 5:00. It's 5:00. It's 5:00. And they say, OK, OK. It's 5:00.
5点了。5点了。5点了。他们试着继续睡。让我睡吧。我说，5点了。5点了。5点了。他们说，好，好。5点了。
Then I get ready for bed. He wakes up and says, OK, see you later. I'll wake you later.
然后我就准备睡觉了。他起来说，好吧，回头见。我晚点再叫你。
And does it feel strange and intimate? Or did it at first when you had to share a bed with somebody?
这感觉奇怪且亲密吗？或者刚开始必须和别人共用一张床时是这样吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
Jose says, yes, of course, yeah. You're used to coming to work. And suddenly someone else comes and sleeps in your bed, in your blankets. You should see. It's weird. You flip your pillow over each time.
何塞说，是的，当然。你习惯来上班。突然另一个人来了，睡在你的床上，钻进你的被子里。你应该看看。这很奇怪。你每次都要翻个面。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
But you get used to it, to everyone's smells. We become friends. You know that if he showers, it's fine, but if not, I understand.
但你习惯了，习惯了所有人的味道。我们成了朋友。你知道如果他洗澡了，那就好，但如果没洗，我也理解。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
Because sometimes you don't get back until 7:00 or 6:00, and there's no time to shower. I'm understanding of that, and he should be too. It's fine. I mean, you get used to it, really.
因为有时你直到7点或6点才回来，根本没时间洗澡。我理解这一点，他应该也是。没关系。我的意思是，你真的会习惯的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
That's what everyone kept telling me, you get used to it-- to the hours, to the work, to everyone else rummaging around in your space. You get used to it.
这就是每个人一直在告诉我的，你会习惯的——习惯时间，习惯工作，习惯周围空间里乱糟糟的一切。你会习惯的。
Jose and Antonio work seven days a week, 16 hours three days a week, eight hours the other four, no overtime. I talked to a guy who's worked closely with many farms across the state, and he described the pay and living conditions at the farm we were at as, quote, "slightly below average."
何塞和安东尼奥一周工作七天，三天每天工作16小时，其余四天每天8小时，没有加班费。我和一个在州内许多农场密切合作的人谈过，他描述了我们所处农场的工资和生活条件，引用他的话说，“略低于平均水平”。
Jose says it's not that bad. He says other farms he's lived at have been worse. At one, the roof leaked onto the beds. And it was so crowded that he'd try to sleep standing up.
何塞说没那么糟。他说他住过的其他农场更烂。有一个地方，屋顶漏水滴到床上。而且太挤了，他试着站着睡觉。
At another, he couldn't sleep, because he was afraid that a drunk, violent roommate would beat him up in the middle of the night. Here, they get along. If someone wants to bring his girlfriend over, the rest of them all cram into the other bedroom, even sleep together in one bed so that guy can have a room to himself.
另一个地方，他睡不着，因为害怕喝醉了的暴力室友半夜会打他。在这里，他们相处得来。如果有人想带女朋友过来，其他人都会挤进另一个房间，甚至挤在一张床上，好让那个人能有自己的私人空间。
But mostly, they're not too concerned about privacy. As I squeezed passed piles of other people's toiletries and clothes and sheets, and condom wrappers all over the floor, I was reminded of what a luxury it is to ever feel like you have a space that's all yours.
但他们大部分时间并不太关心隐私。当我挤过别人的洗漱用品、衣服、床单和满地的避孕套包装时，我想起了拥有一个完全属于自己的空间是多么奢侈的事。
Here, at any given moment, somebody might be in the next room bumping the Black Eyed Peas off YouTube and singing at the top of their lungs.
在这里，随时随地，可能隔壁房间有人正在从YouTube上播放“黑眼豆豆”的歌，还在扯着嗓子大唱。
(SINGING) Here we go. Here we go. We gonna rock, rock, rock. Easy come. Easy go.
(唱歌)我们走吧。我们走吧。我们要摇滚，摇滚，摇滚。容易来。容易走。
This is a guy named Antonio singing. He got really excited at this part, because he knew the days of the week in English.
这个人叫安东尼奥。他对这一段特别兴奋，因为他知道一周中几天的英文表达。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
(SINGING) Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, and Thursday, Friday--
(唱歌)周一，周二，周三，周四，周五——
Well, most of the days. All this is bearable because it's temporary. They do this a few years, then move home.
好吧，大部分日子。这一切都是可以忍受的，因为是暂时的。他们这样做几年，然后搬回家。
And Antonio tells me he makes more in one day here than he would in a whole week in Mexico, and sends it all back. One man says he actually owns his own farm in Mexico, with his own workers, and that he's working here to be able to expand it.
安东尼奥告诉我，他在这里一天赚的比在墨西哥一周赚的还多，而且全都寄了回去。有一个人说他实际上在墨西哥拥有自己的农场，有自己的工人，他在这里工作是为了能扩大规模。
Many guys have built businesses. One is putting two kids through college. Jose says he bought a big house for his girlfriend in Mexico.
很多人都建立了事业。有一个人正在供两个孩子读大学。何塞说他在墨西哥给女朋友买了一栋大房子。
Another man puts it best. He says, every head is its own world. I come for my dreams, and he comes for his.
另一个人说得最好。他说，每个头脑都是一个世界。我为我的梦想而来，他为他的而来。
One of the things Antonio-- the guy who was singing-- dreams about is his bed, his future bed. He can picture exactly what his bedroom in Mexico will look like once he's finished building it.
安东尼奥——那个唱歌的人——梦想的事情之一就是他的床，他未来的床。一旦他盖好了，他就能清楚地想象出他在墨西哥的卧室是什么样子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
With a sturdy red floor, that's a color I like. The bedrooms each have a bathroom.
铺着结实的红色地板，那是我就喜欢的颜色。卧室里都有个卫生间。
[SPANISH] with internet, [SPANISH], Netflix.
[西班牙语]有互联网，[西班牙语]，Netflix。
What size bed do you want? And is it firm, or is it soft?
你想要多大的床？是硬的还是软的？
King size, no? [SPANISH].
特大号，对吧？[西班牙语]。
King sized waterbed. It's the best, no?
特大号水床。那是最好的，对吧？
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
That's why we're here. Antonio cracks another Corona. It's getting late for him. He has to get up in six hours for his shift.
这就是我们在这里的原因。安东尼奥又开了一罐科罗拉啤酒。对他来说时间不早了。他还要在六小时后起来换班。
I shake his hand, but before I go, I notice that I don't smell the manure anymore. I haven't smelled it in a while, actually. The air seems cold and fresh. They're right. You really can get used to the smell.
我和他握了握手，但在离开之前，我发现我不再闻到粪便的味道了。实际上，我已经有一会儿没闻到了。空气似乎变得清凉而清新。他们是对的。你确实可以习惯那种气味。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, "The Haunted Becomes the Haunter." This next story is about two women who aren't sleeping in the same bed. They're kind of inhabiting the same body, in a way, with very different dreams. Miki Meek tells what happened.
第三幕，《被闹鬼者成了闹鬼者》。下一个故事是关于两个女人，她们没有同床，但以某种方式占据着同一个身体，怀揣着截然不同的梦想。米基·米克讲述了发生了什么。
Jessamyn Lovell didn't know she had a secret doppelganger until she got a phone call. Jessamyn is a photographer who teaches photography at the University of New Mexico in Albuquerque. And one morning, she was heading out the door for work.
杰萨敏·洛弗尔不知道自己有个秘密的替身，直到接到一个电话。杰萨敏是一位摄影师，在新墨西哥大学阿尔伯克基分校教授摄影。那天早上，她正出门去上班。
And I get this call, and he identified himself as Inspector Crudo from the San Francisco Police Department Financial Crimes Unit. And he immediately asked me, "do you know a woman named Erin Colleen Hart?" And I said "no, and why?"
我接到了这个电话，他自称是旧金山警察局金融犯罪组的克鲁多督察。他立即问我：“你认识一个叫艾琳·科琳·哈特的人吗？”我说：“不认识，为什么？”
And he said, "well, did you ever give her your identification, your New Mexico State driver's license, or any other identification?" And I said, "no, no. I don't know her." And "what is this about?" And I immediately thought of my wallet being stolen a year and a half prior at this gallery in San Francisco.
他说：“好吧，你给过她你的证件吗，你的新墨西哥州驾照，或其他任何证件？”我说：“不，没有。我不认识她。”“这是怎么回事？”我立刻想起了我一年半前在旧金山那家画廊被盗的钱包。
She never got it back, and assumed it was gone for good. But now this police inspector was telling her that a woman named Erin Hart had just been busted using Jessamyn's driver's license, trying to check into a San Francisco hotel.
她再也没拿回来，以为丢了就丢了。但现在这位警督告诉她，一个叫艾琳·哈特的人刚因冒用杰萨敏的驾照试图入住旧金山一家酒店而被捕。
Then he, said, look, I'll send you a police report. She's in police custody right now.
然后他说，听着，我会发给你一份警察报告。她现在被关在警局。
And she was in police custody because she had been trying to use your ID?
她被关起来是因为她试图用你的身份证？
Yeah, exactly. I don't know, I just kind of thought, that sucks that that happened, and that's that, and whatever.
是的，没错。我不知道，我只是觉得，发生这种事真倒霉，事情就是这样，随便吧。
But then about a week after that, it became clear that Jessamyn's license had been used at more places than just the hotel. A collections agency demanded payment from Jessamyn for $500 worth of goods from a Whole Foods store. Unpaid parking tickets and toll evasions also started showing up in her mailbox. And then the rental car company, Hertz, began hounding her for thousands of dollars in charges.
但就在那之后大约一周，杰萨敏的驾照不仅在酒店被使用了。一家催债机构要求杰萨敏支付500美元的全食超市商品费用。未付的停车罚单和逃避通行费也开始出现在她的信箱里。然后赫兹租车公司开始为数千美元的费用纠缠她。
I figured out and added it up, and it was all, like, three different cars that she had rented. So one she just returned. Another one she had clearly damaged. And another one, the boot had been put on it, and there were tickets, and whatever. I knew I had not rented these cars, and yet they would not believe me. [CHUCKLES] They would not believe me.
我算了一下，这总共是三辆不同的车，她租的。一辆她刚退租。另一辆显然被她损坏了。还有一辆被锁了轮胎，还有罚单之类的。我知道我没有租过这些车，但他们不相信我。[轻笑]他们不相信我。
She was spending all her time on the phone and email, trying to tell them and other places that she'd been a victim of identity theft. And then Jessamyn got a summons to appear in court from Alameda County Court in Oakland. The charge against her was petty theft.
她把所有时间都花在电话和邮件上，试图告诉他们和其他地方她是身份盗窃的受害者。然后杰萨敏收到了奥克兰阿拉米达县法院的传票。对她的指控是轻微盗窃。
So I was really freaked out. This must be connected to her, this woman, Erin Hart.
我真的很害怕。这一定和她有关，那个女人，艾琳·哈特。
So she bought a plane ticket on a credit card and flew to Oakland. Once Jessamyn got there, she sat around in a courtroom all morning, waiting to be called up.
于是她用信用卡买了一张机票飞往奥克兰。一旦杰萨敏到了那里，她整个上午都坐在法庭里，等着被传唤。
I was getting more and more ramped up. It felt like a lot of people were getting taken away.
我越来越紧张。感觉就像很多人被带走了。
Until she was finally the last person in the room.
直到她成了房间里最后一个人。
And then the judge asked me, "are you the one that sent this big pile of papers in to me?" And I was like, "yes. Those are all the documents." She's like, "OK. I'm going to look through them really quickly here."
法官问我：“是你把这一大堆文件寄给我的吗？”我说：“是的。那些都是文件。”她说：“好吧。我这就快速看一遍。”
OK, what was in there again?
好吧，里面又是什么？
All of the Hertz stuff, and then the police report, just to show, believe me, this isn't the only thing. There's all this other stuff going on.
所有赫兹的东西，还有警察报告，只是为了证明，相信我，这不是唯一一件事。还有其他所有正在发生的事情。
The judge dismissed the case but told Jessamyn she should get the charge expunged so it wouldn't appear on background checks, which was going to be a whole other hassle. She walked out of the courtroom, and she was still completely worked up.
法官驳回了此案，但告诉杰萨敏她应该申请撤销案底，这样就不会出现在背景调查中，那将是又一个麻烦。她走出法庭时，依然完全处于亢奋状态。
How much was this going to cost her? Who was this woman? And what else had she done posing as Jessamyn?
这要花她多少钱？这个女人是谁？她还冒充杰萨敏做了什么？
I thought immediately, I'm going to get to the bottom of this. I'm going to figure this out. I want to know what it was she did. I want to know how she got my ID. I wanted to find her. I wanted to find her.
我立刻想，我要把这件事查个水落石出。我要弄清楚这一点。我想知道她做了什么。我想知道她是怎么得到我的身份证的。我想找到她。我想找到她。
This is where Jessamyn's story changes from a garden variety identity theft case to something stranger. She had a photocopy of Erin Hart's driver's license in the file she took to court. So she pulled it out and looked at the home address listed on it.
这就是杰萨敏的故事从普通的身份盗窃案转变为更奇怪事件的地方。她在提交给法院的文件中有一份艾琳·哈特驾照的复印件。所以她把它拿出来，看了看上面列出的家庭住址。
I had enough drive, just adrenaline, that I was like, I'm going there, just like, I'm doing this thing.
我当时动力十足，全是肾上腺素，我觉得：我要去那儿，就像这样，我要做这件事。
And what was the thing that you were thinking you were going to do?
你当时想做的事是什么？
I don't know. I mean, I seriously-- I wish I could tell you I had a plan and I had something I was going to say, and I just didn't. And I remember thinking, well, I want to park close enough that I can run and get into my car if I have to. [LAUGHS] I'm not even kidding, I really did think that.
我不知道。我是说，我认真地——我真希望我能告诉你我有个计划，想好了要说什么，但我根本没有。我记得当时在想，嗯，我要把车停在足够近的地方，这样如果必须的话，我可以跑回去开车。[笑]我不是开玩笑，我真的那么想过。
It was this huge, huge, huge, huge, huge apartment building. And I got in. Someone went in, and I just snuck in after them. I'm going in. I know her apartment number. I'm going to go in.
那是一栋巨大、巨大、巨大、巨大、巨大的公寓楼。我进去了。有人走了进去，我趁机溜了进去。我进去了。我知道她的公寓号码。我要进去了。
And so I'm walking through the halls, and I'd found the apartment. I just went up to it and knocked on it. And no one answered the door. And then I'm relieved. And I'm like, OK, well, I have to leave. And then I photographed the door, maybe one of the most boring pictures ever taken in my life.
所以我走在走廊里，找到了那间公寓。我走上前敲了敲门。没人开门。然后我松了口气。我想：好吧，我得走了。然后我拍了那扇门的照片，可能是我这辈子拍过最无聊的照片之一。
Wait, why? Like why take a picture?
等等，为什么？为什么要拍照？
I almost wanted just to have the evidence for myself that you went there, you did this. Almost like, I mean, I don't want to overstate it, but like a tourist's documents. I kind of felt like I needed to have this pin drop there. I know it sounds crazy in hindsight. It kind of does sound a little weird in hindsight.
我几乎只是想保留证据证明我到过那里，我做了这件事。几乎就像是，我是说，我不夸大其词，就像游客的文件一样。我感觉我需要在这儿投下这一枚别针。回想起来这听起来很疯狂。回想起来确实显得有点古怪。
Jessamyn also went to the Hertz counter in San Francisco, where three cars were rented in her name, and the Whole Foods in Berkeley where she had a $500 debt, and Hotel Vitale. That's where Erin Hart got arrested trying to check in with her license. Walking in, Jessamyn saw that it was the type of hotel she'd never be able to stay at.
杰萨敏还去了旧金山的赫兹柜台，在那里以她的名义租了三辆车，还去了伯克利的全食超市，她那里有500美元的债务，还有维塔利酒店。艾琳·哈特就是在那儿因为试图持杰萨敏的证件入住而被捕的。走进去时，杰萨敏发现那是她永远住不起的酒店。
And I was not prepared for how fancy this place was going to be. Right away, coming in the door, they had wine, or they had tea. And the hotel staff immediately asked me if they could help me.
我没有准备好这个地方会这么奢华。一进门，他们就提供了红酒，或者茶。酒店员工立即问我是否需要帮助。
And as soon as I said this woman had tried to check in here with my ID, the guy knew. And actually, he said that usually when this happens-- and I was like, oh, this happens a lot? And he's like, yes. And when that happens, we ask them to leave, and they leave. And he said, this woman didn't leave.
当我说这个女人曾试图用我的证件入住这里时，那个人知道。实际上他说，通常发生这种情况时——我就问，哦，这种事经常发生吗？他说：是的。当这种情况发生时，我们会请他们离开，他们就离开了。他说，这个女人没走。
The manager knew Erin was a fraud, because she got Jessamyn's name wrong when she checked in. She had a beautifully groomed Persian cat with her, and was standing in the lobby insisting that the license was hers. That's when the manager decided to call the police.
经理知道艾琳是骗子，因为她入住时报错了杰萨敏的名字。她带了一只打理得很漂亮的波斯猫，站在大堂坚称驾照是她的。这时经理决定报警。
So they arrested her, and they took her away. And the cat was just left there with her stuff. And they were like, well, I guess we'll have to call animal humane. And then she came a couple days later-- she was released-- and asked for her cat at the hotel.
所以他们逮捕了她，把她带走了。猫就和她的东西一起留在那儿。他们说，嗯，我想我们得打给动物人道协会。然后几天后她来了——她被释放了——在酒店寻找她的猫。
And they said, well, I'm sorry. We sent her to-- and she was really upset that the cat wasn't there. That definitely was the first moment where I had any kind of sympathy for her. And they gave her the number for animal humane. And then she left. Now when I went to animal humane.
他们说，嗯，很抱歉。我们把它送到——她对猫不在那里感到非常难过。那绝对是我第一次对她产生任何同情心的时刻。他们给了她动物人道协会的号码。然后她走了。现在我去了动物人道协会。
Wait, you went to animal humane to also track down the cat?
等等，你也是去动物人道协会追踪那只猫吗？
Well, to see if she had been there. And nobody knew anything about her or the cat. And so I just, OK, and I just left. And then I photographed the outside.
嗯，去看看她有没有去过那里。没人知道关于她或猫的任何信息。所以我只是“哦”，然后我就离开了。接着我拍了外部的照片。
So Jessamyn goes home to New Mexico. But she just can't let this go. She's still dealing with the fallout, fighting with Hertz and a few other places over bills. And she decides to do a bunch of things that most of us would not do.
所以杰萨敏回到了新墨西哥州。但她就是没法放下这件事。她还在处理后果，与赫兹和其他一些地方争论账单。她决定做一些大多数人不会做的事。
First, Jessamyn sends a letter to Erin's address saying, basically, I know what you did, and here's what it's done to me. She includes an invoice for $1,200, the total cost of her round trip flight to California combined with an hourly rate for her time.
首先，杰萨敏给艾琳的地址寄了一封信，基本上说：我知道你做了什么，这对我造成了什么影响。她附上了一张1200美元的账单，这是她往返加州的总费用，加上她花费时间的小时费率。
And then months later, Jessamyn finds herself back in San Francisco for work. And she picks up Erin's trail again. She has a list of old addresses Erin had lived at, maybe 20 of them, that she got from a private investigator.
几个月后，杰萨敏发现自己为了工作又回到了旧金山。她再次捡起了艾琳的线索。她有一份艾琳住过的旧地址清单，可能20个，是从私人调查员那里弄来的。
And she starts going from place to place, visiting Erin's old apartments. At one point, Jessamyn pulls up to this gorgeous building overlooking the Bay Bridge. At the time, Jessamyn was seven months pregnant, and she thinks, well, maybe I can use this to my advantage.
她开始从一个地方走到另一个地方，拜访艾琳的旧公寓。有一次，杰萨敏把车开到一栋俯瞰海湾大桥的华丽建筑前。当时，杰萨敏已经怀孕七个月了，她想：嗯，也许我可以利用这一点。
I went to the front desk, the security officer. And I was like, hey, as you can see, I'm pregnant. I really have to go to the bathroom. I'm looking for my cousin, Erin Hart. But I need to use the restroom first. Do you mind?
我去了前台，保安人员那儿。我说：嘿，如你所见，我怀孕了。我真的得去个洗手间。我在找我的表妹艾琳·哈特。但我得先用一下洗手间。你不介意吧？
And she was like, Erin Hart? Yeah, I know her. She used to live here. The woman actually knew her boyfriend at the time.
她说：艾琳·哈特？是的，我认识她。她曾经住这儿。那个女人竟然认识她当时那个男朋友。
She's like, "now I don't know for sure, and it's just gossip, but I had heard that she had had several thousand dollars of his possessions or whatever that she took off with and never came back." And I was like, "oh wow. OK, jeez." You know. And she's like, "well, you know Erin," or whatever. And I was like, "oh yeah, totally."
她说：“嗯，我不能确定，这只是道听途说，但我听说她拿走了他价值好几千美元的财产之类的东西，然后一去不回。”我说：“哦哇。好吧，天哪。”你知道。她说：“嗯，你知道艾琳的。”之类的。我说：“哦，对，确实。”
Erin's old boyfriend didn't live there anymore. So Jessamyn took a few pictures inside the building and then moved on to the other addresses. All of them were dead ends.
艾琳的前男友已经不住那里了。所以杰萨敏在楼里拍了几张照片，然后就转往其他地址了。所有地址都走进了死胡同。
I mean, is there any part of you that is kind of feeling like a creep?
我是说，你有没有哪部分觉得自己像个变态？
I knew it was cra-- like, I knew that it was not healthy. I did know that. But I could not let it go as just something someone did to me that I had no control over.
我知道这很——我的意思是，我知道这不健康。我确实知道。但我不能把这件事仅仅当成别人对我做了我无法控制的事情而置之不理。
Jessamyn hates feeling like she's lost control. And whenever it happens, ever since she was a teenager, she's dealt with it the same sort of way.
杰萨敏讨厌感觉自己失去了控制。只要这种情况发生，从她十几岁起，她就用同样的方式处理。
When she was around 11, her dad abandoned the family, her mom and her three younger siblings. Then they lost their house. And for a while, they all lived in a van with her cat and dog. Her dad, he did some pretty extreme things.
她11岁左右时，她爸爸抛弃了家庭，她的妈妈和三个年幼的兄弟姐妹。然后他们失去了房子。有一阵子，他们全家人和她的猫狗住在一辆小货车里。她爸爸做了一些相当极端的事。
My dad tried to have me kidnapped.
我爸爸试图绑架我。
He tried to kidnap you or sent someone?
他试图绑架你或者派人？
He tried to have someone come and kidnap me at my school, and then again later in a park. And my family, we ended up going for some time up to Canada so that he couldn't find us.
他试图让人来学校绑架我，后来又在公园里又来了一次。我们一家人最后搬到加拿大住了一段时间，这样他就找不到我们了。
Later, Jessamyn's mom got really sick. And suddenly she found herself taking care of her entire family. At some point, as a way to deal with all the chaos, she started taking pictures, things like an ambulance driving her mom away, screaming matches between her sisters, trash strewn all over their trailer home.
后来，杰萨敏的妈妈病得很重。突然间她发现自己在照顾整个家庭。在某个时候，为了应对混乱，她开始拍照，比如一辆救护车拉走她妈妈、她姐妹们之间的尖叫对骂、拖车家里到处都是垃圾。
She'd methodically document what she was going through. And it gave her a sense of control. She continued to use her camera that way as an adult. At one point, eight years ago, she had a brief scare that reminded her of her dad, a random incident where she wondered if he was following her again.
她有条不紊地记录下她所经历的一切。这给了她一种控制感。成年后她继续以这种方式使用相机。八年前，她有过一次短暂的恐慌，让她想起了她爸爸，一个偶然事件，让她怀疑他是否又在跟踪她。
From that night on, I had it in my head I wanted to find him. But I didn't want to find him and talk to him.
从那天晚上起，我就在脑子里想找到他。但我不想找到他和他谈话。
What's the thing that you wanted?
你想要什么？
I wanted to see him. I wanted to first just find him. I just wanted to know if I could find him, so I did. I did a bunch of searching and background checks and Google stuff. And he was about three and a half hours north of where I lived.
我想见他。我想先找到他。我只是想知道我能不能找到他，所以我做到了。我做了很多搜索、背景调查和谷歌搜索之类的。他在我住处以北大约三个半小时车程的地方。
Jessamyn was living in Oakland at the time. And her dad was just north of her, living in a condo on the Mendocino coast. She started making covert trips up there.
杰萨敏当时住在奥克兰。她爸爸就在她北边，住在门多西诺海岸的一套公寓里。她开始对他进行秘密观察。
And she never knew how to explain this to her friends. So she kept it simple and told them, oh, I'm going to spend the weekend with my dad, which technically was true. It's just that she did it wearing a blonde wig, and from a distance.
她不知道怎么向朋友解释这件事。所以她简单地说了，哦，我要去陪我爸过周末，这在技术上是真的。只是她穿着金发假发，而且保持距离。
Well, I had a telephoto lens and was really far away. I was like out in the woods. I could get a mile or so away if I needed to.
嗯，我有一个长焦镜头，站得很远。我像是待在树林里。如果需要的话，我可以离一英里远。
What did you see?
你看到了什么？
He was on the deck. He was out for a walk. He would go to the gym, taking out the trash.
他在甲板上。他出来散步。他会去健身房，去倒垃圾。
And he never saw you?
他从没看见你？
No, no.
没有，没有。
When you were stalking your dad, or you were following your dad?
当你跟踪你爸时，或者你在跟随你爸时？
I was observing him from a distance.
我是在远处观察他。
Observing him. And so what did that feel like?
观察他。那种感觉如何？
It felt really good to see him, and him not know I was there.
能看见他，而他不知道我在那里，感觉真好。
Because why?
因为为什么？
Because I had some knowledge about who he was and what he was doing. It was like a one-way mirror. I could see in, and he couldn't see me, you know. And it felt like I had some kind of power.
因为我掌握了他的一些信息，了解他是谁在做什么。那就像一面单向镜。我可以往里看，他却看不见我，你知道吗。这感觉就像我拥有了某种力量。
I don't know much about the identity theft business. But I'm guessing that the ideal target does not own a camera that can photograph you from a mile away. Two years after Jessamyn got that phone call from the police, she was still trying to track Erin down. And in February 2013, her private investigator let her know that he found Erin. She was back in jail and about to be released.
我对身份盗窃业务了解不多。但我猜理想的目标不会拥有一台能从一英里外拍到你的相机。杰萨敏接到警察那个电话两年后，她还在尝试追踪艾琳。2013年2月，她的私人调查员通知她找到了艾琳。她又在监狱里，快要被释放了。
Jessamyn went with him to a jail in downtown San Francisco. She brought a telephoto lens and a video camera. And the two of them sat around in his SUV for hours, waiting. Her PI had a contact who told him Erin might come out the back.
杰萨敏和他一起去了旧金山市中心的一个监狱。她带了一个长焦镜头和一台录像机。他们俩在SUV里坐了几个小时，等待着。她的PI有一个线人，告诉他艾琳可能会从后门出来。
She's going to come out the back here soon.
她很快就会从后面出来了。
Hopefully. One by one, people were coming out. And the entire time, I'm just like photographing. I had this lens pointed at the door. And terrified that she's not going to come out, she's not going to come out. We're not going to find her. And we see her.
希望如此。人们一个接一个地出来。整个过程中，我一直在拍照。我把这个镜头对着门。害怕她出不来，她出不来。我们找不到她。然后我们看到了她。
Here she comes.
她来了。
Here she comes. Is that her?
她来了。那是她吗？
Yep.
是的。
Yes, that's her.
没错，就是她。
[INAUDIBLE]. OK, we got her.
[听不清]。好吧，抓到她了。
Erin Hart walked right past their car. She had a couple bags hanging off her shoulder. And she was dressed, Jessamyn thought, like she was going to a nightclub-- tight black shirt, shiny pants, and wedge boots.
艾琳·哈特直接走过他们的车。她肩膀上挂着几个袋子。杰萨敏心想，她的打扮就像要去夜店一样——紧身黑衬衫、亮面裤子和坡跟靴。
Immediately I thought, oh my gosh, we do kind of look similar. She was a similar build to me, which is sort of tallish, 5' 7", 5' 8", but fuller figured, wider hips. And I could see that she had a roundish face, like I do.
我立刻想，天哪，我们确实长得挺像。她的体型跟我类似，就是比较高，5英尺7、8英寸，但身形丰满，臀部较宽。我能看出她有一张圆脸，就像我一样。
And she has this bright orange hair. And I just thought of my days in my teenage years dying my hair that exact orange, this super bright orange. And I just felt this uncanny connection to her. I really did. And then from there on, for the next several hours, was just, you know, adrenaline.
她染了一头亮橘色的头发。我不禁想起了我十几岁时把头发染成那种一模一样的橘色的日子，那种超级鲜艳的橘色。我真的对她感到一种不可思议的联系。真的。从那以后接下来的几个小时里，剩下的只有肾上腺素。
She's on foot. She's on foot.
她在步行。她在步行。
Let me call Jerel and tell him.
让我打给杰瑞尔告诉他。
They had two other PIs working with them in a separate car. They all trailed Erin, whose first stop was a convenience store, where she went in to buy cigarettes and a lighter. She hung outside for a few minutes smoking, and then got on a public bus.
他们另外两个PI在另一辆车里为他们工作。他们都跟踪艾琳，她的第一站是一家便利店，她进去买香烟和打火机。她在外面抽了一会儿烟，然后坐上了公共汽车。
(WHISPERING) Where is she going?
(耳语)她去哪儿？
She's going to Goodwill.
她要去好邻居旧货店。
Erin got off right in front of a Goodwill store and walked in.
艾琳直接在好邻居店前下了车，走了进去。
Right away, Pete says, "jump out and go in there. Go after her." And I was like, "oh, should I talk to her?" You know, I'm thinking, oh, OK.
皮特立刻说：“跳下车进去。跟上她。”我说：“哦，我应该跟她说话吗？”你知道，我在想，哦，好吧。
He's like, "no, no, no. Don't talk to her. Just go in, get your photographs. Get a good look at her. Just go, go, go." And so I'm jumping out, like freaking out, like, oh my god. He's just leaving me here with her. Like, what do I-- and then I see Nate and Jerel in there.
他说：“不，不，不。别跟她说话。只要进去，拍下照片。仔细看看她。快，快，快。”所以我跳下车，吓得半死，天哪。他竟然把我一个人留在这儿陪她。像，我该怎么办——然后我看到内特和杰瑞尔在那儿。
The other PIs.
其他的PI。
Yeah. I'm like, OK. So I'm looking at them for cues. And they're not remotely giving me any kind of cues. And then I just go for it, and I go up to her, and I don't say anything to her. I just stand right across the rack of clothes in the Goodwill from her as she's going through, pulling clothes out, looking, changing her mind, very expressive. Like, oh, no, I would never wear that. I could kind of hear in my mind what she might be thinking from her expression.
是的。我想，好吧。所以我看着他们寻求信号。他们一点儿都没给我任何信号。然后我就豁出去了，直接走上前，我什么也没对她说。我只是站在她对面隔着衣服架子，看着她在挑选、拉出衣服、观看、改变主意，非常生动。像，哦，不，我永远不会穿那件。从她的表情中我似乎能听到她在想什么。
And I'm at an angle where I feel like she can't really tell what I'm doing, like maybe I'm just checking my email or something, and I'm just looking at my phone. And I take some photos of her.
我站在一个她感觉不到我在做什么的角度，可能以为我只是在查邮件之类的，我盯着手机。我拍了她几张照片。
But how nervous are you? I mean, literally, now you're face to face.
但你有多紧张？我是说，真的，现在你们面对面了。
I'm shaking. I'm very nervous, definitely. And I think there's a part of me that is still thinking, I could just talk to her right now. Erin. Hey, Erin. Like I could just say that.
我在发抖。我很紧张，绝对的。我想我内心还有一部分在想：我现在可以直接跟她说话。艾琳。嘿，艾琳。就像我可以随便说出来一样。
I could hear myself saying, Erin Hart, I know you probably don't recognize me. I know you don't know me. But I am Laurel Jessamyn Lovell. And you used my ID to do a number of things.
我能听到自己说：艾琳·哈特，我知道你可能不认识我。我知道你不认识我。但我叫杰萨敏·洛弗尔。你用了我的身份证做了不少事情。
But the power for me was in seeing her without her knowing that I was seeing her. And then she disappears into the dressing room. And that's when the other PI comes over to me and says she's stealing clothes. And I was like, what?
但对我来说，力量在于看着她，而她不知道我在看着她。然后她消失在更衣室里。这时另一个PI过来对我说，她在偷衣服。我说，什么？
I just needed to get out of there. I was overwhelmed. I was feeling really sad for her. And I didn't want to feel sad for her. I wanted to feel angry at her.
我只是需要离开那里。我不知所措。我对她感到很难过。而且我不想对她感到难过。我想对她生气。
It was hard to maintain the anger, because she was looking at Erin and remembering things she'd done when she was young and her family was broke.
维持愤怒很难，因为她看着艾琳，想起了她年轻时家庭没钱时做过的事情。
I had shoplifted nice cheese, or I literally stole arugula, things that I thought and associated with class, middle to upper middle class. And I think that's what really was giving me this sympathy for Erin Hart was I could identify, in a way, with the desire to be someone else.
我偷过好奶酪，或者字面上偷过芝麻菜，我认为与阶级、中产阶级到中上阶级相关的东西。我认为这才是真正让我对艾琳·哈特产生同情心的原因，因为我可以理解那种想要成为别人的渴望。
I could see how a path in my life could have led to my being in that moment. I really could. But it was, I guess, a little disappointing. I guess it was a little like, oh, I kind of wanted it to be like she was a criminal and did something bad to me.
我能看出我的人生路径怎么可能导致我在那一刻。我真的能。但这，我猜，有点令人失望。我猜有点像，哦，我本想它是像她是个罪犯，对我做了什么坏事。
And it just wasn't that. None of that satisfaction of I got her. It was just this weird transition. And anger was starting to be sort of replaced with empathy.
结果并不是那样。那种“我抓到她了”的满足感完全没有。这只是一个奇怪的过渡。愤怒开始被同情所取代。
What Jessamyn did next doesn't sound empathetic at all when you first hear about it. But for Jessamyn, it was the logical end of her search. She went through the hundreds of images she'd taken, and she put together a gallery exhibit. It had surveillance shots of Erin, the court summons, police reports, bills, and pictures of places where her ID had been used.
当你第一次听到杰萨敏接下来做的事时，听起来一点也不显得同情。但对杰萨敏来说，这是她搜索的逻辑终点。她翻遍了拍下的数百张照片，整理成一个画廊展览。里面有监护摄像拍到的艾琳、传票、警察报告、账单，以及她身份证被使用的地点的照片。
She had done this once before with the surveillance photos she took of her dad. In fact, her wallet was stolen while she was setting up that exhibit, which is what sent her down the rabbit hole of trying to find Erin in the first place. She called the new show, "Dear Erin Hart."
她曾为她爸爸的监控照片做过一次这样的事。实际上，她钱包被偷就是在她筹备那个展览时，那也是导致她钻进寻找艾琳这个兔子洞的原因。她把新展览命名为“亲爱的艾琳·哈特”。
And one of the items on display was a sealed letter in a Plexiglas box. She asked the people at the gallery to give it to Erin if she ever showed up there. It wasn't a dramatic letter, just a way of telling Erin that she'd been looking for her and wanted to talk.
展品中有一件是一个有机玻璃盒里的一封封好的信。她要求画廊的人，如果艾琳出现，就把信交给她。那不是一封戏剧性的信，只是为了告诉艾琳，她一直在寻找她并想聊聊。
Jessamyn didn't see putting Erin's name and photos out in public as revenge. But not everyone saw it that way.
杰萨敏并没有把将艾琳的名字和照片公开视为报复。但并不是每个人都那么看。
If you were a victim of identity theft, would you consider tracking down the thief and turning the tables?
如果你是身份盗窃的受害者，你会考虑追踪窃贼并反戈一击吗？
This is from the Today Show .
这是来自《今日秀》的节目。
In an act some have described as revenge, Lovell followed and photographed the woman who stole her wallet, and then her identity.
在一些人描述为报复的行为中，洛弗尔追踪并拍摄了偷走她钱包、后来又盗用她身份的那个女人。
I reached out to Erin Hart through her probation officer to talk about all this. I sent a couple emails listing everything Jessamyn says about her. But Erin never got back to me. So I couldn't verify whether she was responsible for bills Jessamyn got from Hertz and Whole Foods, or any of the unpaid parking tickets and tolls, or whether she shoplifted from Goodwill or stole from her boyfriend.
我通过她的缓刑监督官联系了艾琳·哈特，想谈谈这一切。我发了几封邮件，列出了杰萨敏关于她的一切说法。但艾琳从没回复我。所以我无法核实她是否要为杰萨敏从赫兹和全食超市收到的账单负责，或者任何未付的停车罚单和通行费，或者她是否在好邻居店顺手牵羊或从男朋友那里偷窃。
So Erin secretly posed as Jessamyn. And Jessamyn secretly photographed Erin. Jessamyn admits it's an uncomfortable thing that they have in common. Each of them is willing to invade someone else's privacy to get what they want.
所以艾琳秘密冒充杰萨敏。杰萨敏秘密拍摄了艾琳。杰萨敏承认，她们共同拥有一种不舒服的事情。她们每个人都愿意侵犯他人的隐私来获得她们想要的东西。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. We thought we would end today's program where we began, on an airplane. At some point in putting together this week's show, it occurred to us that an overnight flight really is just like this huge bed with hundreds of people all together, dreaming different dreams.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。我们想我们以开始的地方结束今天的节目，在一架飞机上。在整理本周节目过程中的某个时刻，我们想到，一架夜航航班确实就像这张数百人共处、怀揣不同梦想的巨床。
And we asked people on two different flights like this to tell us their dreams, and their daydreams, and their hopes and dreams. One of our staff was actually on a red eye flight herself and got on the plane's PA system to explain the premise.
我们请两架不同航班上的人讲述他们的梦想、白日梦，以及他们的希望和梦想。我们的一位员工实际上就在一架红眼航班上，并利用飞机的广播系统解释了这个前提。
May I have your attention, please, ladies and gentlemen? My name is Stephanie Foo.
请注意，女士们先生们？我叫斯蒂芬妮·傅。
Somehow, being on the PA system, she started talking like a flight attendant.
不知怎么的，通过广播系统，她开始像个空乘一样说话。
I am doing a story about this flight.
我正在做关于这个航班的故事。
David Weinberg and Jessica Ament recorded people as well. Here are some of them.
大卫·温伯格和杰西卡·阿门也记录了人们的情况。以下是其中一些。
I was dreaming about old fashioned TV antennas. And then at one point, I felt like I was shaking. And I was sure it was because the plane was shaking. But I was trying to adjust the antenna.
我梦见老式电视天线。然后在某个时刻，我觉得自己在晃动。我很确定这是因为飞机在晃动。但我当时在试图调整天线。
I was dreaming about I was in a hot air balloon. And I was yelling for my dog, hey, Katie, I'm up here.
我梦见我在一个热气球里。我对着我的狗大喊：嘿，凯蒂，我在上面。
Sitting there, semi-lucid, I was thinking of the horned puffins swimming underwater, and how the little bubbles come out of their feathers when they're swimming. And then I thought of them as going along in space and creating stars, and then diving into the center of the galaxy.
坐在那里，半清醒状态下，我想着角海雀在水下游泳，以及它们游泳时羽毛中冒出的小气泡。然后我把它们想象成在太空中穿行并创造恒星，然后潜入银河系的中心。
That's really trippy.
那真是太迷幻了。
Yeah.
是的。
Were you medicated at all?
你当时吃药了吗？
No, not at all. [LAUGHS]
没有，完全没有。[笑]
I had a total nightmare. I was backing down a hill out of a garage with a friend in a VW bus. And we lost control of it and went down the hill. And my friend turned to me and said, you know, I will never forgive you for this.
我做了一个彻头彻尾的噩梦。我正和一个朋友开着一辆大众面包车倒出车库。我们失去了控制，冲下了山坡。我朋友转过身对我说：你知道吗，我永远不会原谅你的。
Everybody says, why would you want to go to New York? Ew, it's so big. And why? You know, and I'm like, because you see all these things on television. I've always wanted to experience a cab ride in New York City. We're going to do it all. We're going to do it all.
每个人都说，你为什么要那么想去纽约？噫，那么大。为什么？你知道，我说因为你在电视上看到了所有这些东西。我一直想体验一下在纽约市坐出租车。我们要全部体验。我们要全部体验。
My daughter's about to have a baby. So I don't know if dream's exactly the right word, but a lot of hopes. It's her first baby, my first grandbaby. Just to put it simply, I definitely didn't live up to my responsibility as her father.
我女儿快生孩子了。所以我不知道“梦想”这个词是否完全准确，但有很多希望。这是她的第一个孩子，我的第一个孙子。简单地说，我绝对没尽到做父亲的责任。
And I had not been a regular part of her life up until she was nine. I blew it. So I'm definitely not going to make the same mistakes that I made with her. I feel like I've been given a second chance.
在她九岁之前我一直没规律地参与她的生活。我搞砸了。所以我绝对不会犯和她当初一样的错误。我觉得我得到了第二次机会。
[MUSIC - "SAME BED, DIFFERENT DREAMS," BY JOHN HOWARD]
[音乐 - “同床异梦”，约翰·霍华德]
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and me with Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Joe Richman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯和我制作，参与人员还有肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、乔·里奇曼、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。
Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell. Production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。乔尔·洛弗尔提供编辑帮助。西蒙·阿德勒提供制作帮助。塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。埃尔娜·贝克为我们节目搜寻故事。米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉提供研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who, of course, stopped by the office. He's wearing the same outfit today he wears every single day.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他当然也顺道来了办公室。他今天穿的衣服和他每天穿的一模一样。
Tight black shirt, shiny pants, wedge boots.
紧身黑衬衫，亮面裤子，坡跟靴。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于美国生活的故事。
[MUSIC - "ONLY IN MY DREAMS," BY DEBBIE GIBSON]
[音乐 - “只在梦中”，黛比·吉布森]